well so
let's talk about twitter twitter had a
bad day yesterday maybe the worst day of
their career
twitter did not have a good day
yesterday it's a kind of a day
that you're giving the government the
opportunity to come after you
and it won't be pretty you're making it
easy for them so here's what happened
yesterday
a story came out from new york post
about hunter biden and i'm going to kind
of give the details about the hunter
biden story yeah wednesday and then from
there it came out wednesday today's
friday came out wednesday
and and then we'll go into how twitter
handled this so hunter brighton received
a 3.5 million dollar wire transfer from
alina
but to reena this is the story in new
york post the fourth largest
publication in america newspaper fourth
largest the richest woman in russia
who is elena gave biden 3.5 million
dollars who's the widow of yuri
lozovkov the former mayor of moscow
senate republicans revealed in their
report on the younger biden's work in
ukraine
baturina is referenced in the 87-page
report which was released wednesday
addressing her payment to biden's
investment firm in early 2014.
patorino became russia's only female
billionaire when her plastics company
integro received a series of moscow
municipal contracts
while her husband was mayor it is set in
providing background on the business
woman meaning she
worked the government to make more money
her and her husband did together
the report described her involvement
with biden as a financial relationship
but declined to
delve deeper into why the wire transfer
was made the probe was found that
batterino sent 11 wire transfers between
may and december of 2015 to a bank
account
belonging to bak usa tech startup that
filed bankruptcy
in march of 2019 hunter writing position
with batorino's natural gas firm which
paid him as much as 50k a month
created an immediate potential conflict
of interest because his dad now
president trump's
democratic opponent in november third
election was involved in the u.s policy
toward ukraine
the report says and then it continues to
say the 87 page reports knows two
american officials george kent former
active duty
chief of mission at the u.s embassy in
kiev and senior department officials
almost touched on race concerns to biden
staff directed to biden respectively
despite the effort to
of these individuals disappears to have
fallen on deaf ears
the report notes that joe biden's staff
received not publicly accused
but burisma owner makula
of corruption even though he allegedly
paid a 7
million dollar bribe to avoid
prosecution
and former assistant secretary of state
of european and eurasian
affairs victoria nolan testified that
confronting
uh oligarchs would send an
anti-corruption message in ukraine and
then it continues in 2014 the
3.5 million dollar bank uh held under
rosemont samantha thornton an investment
firm co-founded by hunter biden report
says
and then there was another uh 11 wires
more than 390 000
240 000 a bunch of other things that
came out of this story pictures came out
instead of hunter biden with
the pipe next to him and donald trump jr
came out with a video yesterday that
went viral
so that story comes out and twitter
knows about it
on twitter if you went to share this
story
your friend the lady who you think is
pretty can you pronounce her name for us
kaylee mcinning kaylee mcinenneny post
this
a new email from ukraine executive to
100 and ask hunter to use his influence
on behalf of the firm paying him 50 000
a month an email with subject urgent
issue obtained by new york post father
joe biden was in charge of ukraine
relations at the time
october 14 2020 that is two days ago
this was taken down and not only was it
taken down
her account was locked twitter has
locked the personal account of white
house press secretary for sharing news
democrats don't like this is what
happened yesterday right
so everybody that tried to share the
story yesterday on twitter twitter
wouldn't allow it
they wouldn't weren't allowed back to
back to back to back to back they
wouldn't allow it okay
so finally the senate came out to
subpoena jack dorsey over blocking of
disputed biden article
moved by gop lawmakers on judiciary
committees follow social media platforms
anyways they went after him this is
election interference we are 19 days out
of election
never before have we had seen active
censorship of a major press publication
with serious allegations of corruption
of one or two candidates for president
never they allowed the russia article
nobody ever stopped any russia tweets
even though all of it was allegations
none of it was true
twitter did this yesterday then finally
jack dorsey comes out and said
we made a mistake but at that point it
was too late your thoughts i'll let you
go first well
um this is going to be very interesting
they're in a lot of trouble
yeah um the republicans control the
senate they are going to get him in
front to testify
they also locked the new york post's
account as well they literally locked
new york post's ability to send out more
tweets
this thing has legs you know it the
the story is that hunter biden you know
brought his computer in for repair never
picked it up
they backed everything up they called
the fbi rudy giuliani saying it's five
we've heard five percent we know about
five percent of what's really on that
and you know giuliani used to be a
prosecutor for the federal government
took down ma
the mafia so he's all over this for the
last five months
um it's time for these guys to face some
really tough questions about something
like this
and get to the bottom of it and you know
a little innocent thing they thought
they were doing
on wednesday by blocking this thing
could come back and
really really i mean do some serious
damage because
social media is a harmful thing and it's
about time we start peeling back the
onion a little bit
and figure out what's going on with some
of these decisions adam what do you
think
get it all out get it all out i'm
surprised there aren't more stories and
they didn't happen sooner
a how much of this is true just a
general question
b let's not pretend that trump and his
kids are completely innocent
uh breaking news everybody politicians
do shady [ __ ] breaking news hunter biden
might be a scumbag is that going to stop
you from
voting left voting right who knows uh
get it all out i i don't know i don't i
haven't really followed hunter biden but
anything i've
heard about the guy is yeah not a good
scumbag hall of fame i mean if you watch
that donald trump jr video and he points
things out
unbelievable of the stuff some of this
stuff is pretty dirty by the way he got
a point he got a porn star pregnant and
says no it wasn't me
he didn't pay attention and they did a
dna testing and ended up being him
and then his brother dies and he gets
together with the brother's
wife which i mean then you're doing
drugs and prostitutes
in russia and half the money that you're
bringing apparently they got to pay to
joe biden
if look all these stories coming out
like like joe biden like is any money
you make of me being a politics anything
you make that side deals you got to pay
me half of it right
let's just say this is [ __ ] right but
let's just say the following let's just
say the following you ready
okay say you and i uh uh
your girl says you're on your phone at
night okay
and you think she's asleep and you're
texting somebody
she's a touring texting so i don't know
nobody just a friend
let me see the phone if you say what
no what do you mean is going on buddy
you're probably texting somebody you
shouldn't be texting you understand what
i'm saying give me the phone no why you
want to see my phone you never trust me
i've never had this conversation
exactly right what you're talking about
so so the point i'm trying to make
right there you're already guilty okay
so there's a story coming out
about hunter biden and the fact that joe
biden did this
no don't share the story no no dude you
screwed up
you should have let the story come out
and say oh it's just another one of
those stories
the fact that you didn't let the story
come out you know what it tells the
world
that all of it is right the cover-up
well wait a minute who tells twitter
don't let the story come out
you tell me i don't know are you telling
me are you saying that it's political
i'll tell you
why why would they why would they not
post the story who cares the biden
campaign
who cares why would you not let the
story come out who cares
remember twitter just has new guidelines
why did it come up with new guidelines
right before elections you're coming up
with new guidelines that only last
during the last two weeks of guidelines
why did you come out with the new
guidelines
because twitter helps switch president
trump or biden trump
so now you come out with two guidelines
that's only going to last during the
election you're going to get away with
these guidelines after the election who
are you trying to help
who's calling who who is calling who
who's calling who when they're using
this
obama said mark's a good friend of mine
when he was running for office
why is it that mark zuckerberg gives his
best uh
advertising guy to pete budecid and then
pete blew up
pete's going to be a future rock star
because he had mark on his side
you get a marco or jack dorsey nowadays
on your side or the guys at google
this is a big benefit so who called them
to say don't let the story
be shared and if who didn't let's let's
just again everything here is what
speculation everything here is
speculation
but if you got nothing to hide
again it goes back to strategy for me if
you care so much about a story coming
out guess what
it's true versus the way you do this is
what
let it come out and yesterday even if it
was brought up oh it's a non-issue it's
not a big deal yeah and especially now
there's always going to be a next story
where those things can be in your rear
view mirror very very quickly
or just devil's advocate here i don't
know hunter biden from nothing
or could it just not be true and you're
saying do not put fake news out oh buddy
stop
you're saying that there's 100 percent
chance you're seriously that naive adam
why are you seriously dead again i put
it out there
how much of this is true 20 of it 50 of
it 100 by the way let me just how much
of this do you think let me let me ask
you a question what did i say
when donald trump jr's uh uh girlfriend
gavin newsom's uh former wife gave the
talk at
the rnc convention what did i say she
was on coke i said she's on something
it could be five hour energy it could be
red bull it's on something you don't
talk like that so
this isn't for me like i am taking sides
dude
this isn't like oh here's what's going
on i'm just no
when you want a story like this to be
hidden you're scared of something
when you have 33 000 emails that you
want to delete you're hiding something
why are you hiding it
why are you hiding by the way i'll give
you the other one to make this
very simple for you trump doesn't want
to show his tax returns
guess what you're hiding so there's a
reason yeah
yeah so this isn't a left or right i'm
not sitting here just saying
if trump doesn't want to show his tax
returns i guarantee you
there is something the world's going to
say damn this guy pays nothing
there's something he's the only guy
hoping this audit lasts forever right
he's loving it
as soon as the audit's done again i'm
telling you i agree with you that
you know you scoffed at this idea when i
said it 20 minutes ago before the
mariachi band but
okay if five percent of what's out there
has come out
and that means 95 and there's stuff
coming out
that doesn't make joe biden look good
and no one knew this
for 47 years no one knew this about him
if more of this gets revealed it plays
into my theory that i don't know if he
really wants to be president i mean
if he really ultimately wants everything
that goes along with this
i mean could get ugly i mean do you
think the new york post is backing down
i mean there'll be more stories this
weekend
you